dallas is it et ce sont des principes
qui ne bouge pas mais la compréhension
rona de ces principes elle a
considérablement évolué au moment de
1950 la loi de séparation des églises et
de l'état est adopté le conflit est
majeur même si en effet l'analyse de
jean baubérot c'est tout à fait juste
il ce ne sont pas les laïcs qui
entendait même derrière la laïcité
le projet d'éradication des religions
c'était ça le l'enjeu mais l'acceptation
fait religieux est ce qu'il l'a emporté
pour dire les choses simplement
et depuis lors il l'a ce que j'ai
proposé d'appeler l'entrée de la
religion dans la démocratie la religion
en l'occurrence étant le catholicisme
romain qui ne l'oublions pas 1905 est
majoritairement anti républicain même
s'il ya déjà des catholiques
républicains au nombre tout à fait
significatif nous avons une considérable
l'évolution de la laïcité dans sa
conception qui fait que ce n'était même
plus dans les années 60 1970 1980
c'était plus un vrai sujet or des
historiens il n'y avait plus de
batailles laïque
le dernière grande bataille lights et
ont joué autour de l'enseignement de
l'école libre comme on disait à l'époque
[Musique]